Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. You cannot trust people who cook as badly as that. After Finland, it is the country with the worst food. The words of that notable culinary critic Jacques Chirac. Of course, Monsieur Chirac's not exactly alone. It's commonly said, even by the English themselves, that English cooking is the worst in the world. And that's George Orwell in In Defence of English Cooking. So Tom Holland and I have come to The Rest is History, not to bury English cooking, but to praise it, at least I
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、提前收看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你不能信任那些做饭那么难吃的人。继芬兰之后，它是世界上食物最糟糕的国家。这是著名美食评论家雅克·希拉克的名言。当然，希拉克的先生并不孤单。人们普遍认为，甚至英国人自己也认为，英国烹饪是世界上最糟糕的。这是乔治·奥威尔在《保卫英国烹饪》中的话。因此，汤姆·霍兰德和我来到《历史的 rest》，不是为了埋葬英国烹饪，而是为了赞美它，至少我
hope so. And our guest, Tom, well, would you like to introduce our guest? Our guest is Penn Vogler, who has written the most sensational book on the entire history of British food. It's called Scoff. And because it's about Britain, the subtitle is A History of Food and Class. Everything's about class in Britain. Everything in Britain is about class. And it's an absolute feast, not just of historical information, but of facts for pub quizzes. So, Dominic, just to try a couple. I know you've read it because it was one of your Sunday times.
希望如此。我们的嘉宾，汤姆，你想介绍一下我们的嘉宾吗？我们的嘉宾是彭·沃格勒，她写了一本关于英国食物整个历史的最轰动的书。这本书叫《Scoff》。因为它是关于英国的，副标题是《食物与阶级史》。在英国，一切都与阶级有关。英国的一切都与阶级有关。这不仅是一场历史信息的盛宴，也是酒吧问答知识的盛宴。所以，多米尼克，就试几个吧。我知道你读过它，因为它是你的《星期日泰晤士报》之一。
Some time ago. Yes, it was a book, wasn't it? Okay. So what is Penn talking about here? In 1748, the French government banned the cultivation of what on the grounds that they caused leprosy? Artichokes potatoes potatoes okay and richard bradley the professor of botany at cambridge said in 1728 that what was agreeable to look at but was definitely dangerous Definitely dangerous. Carrots, sheep, pen, pen. Come on in and put him out of his misery.
不久前。是的，那是一本书，对吧？好吧。那么彭在这里说什么？1748年，法国政府禁止种植什么，理由是它们会导致麻风病？洋蓟 马铃薯 马铃薯 好的，剑桥大学植物学教授理查德·布拉德利在1728年说，什么东西看起来很讨人喜欢，但绝对是危险的？绝对危险。胡萝卜，羊肉，彭，彭。快来帮他解脱吧。
The cousin of potatoes, it's tomatoes. We're not very good in Britain at kind of absorbing vegetables from, you know, foreign countries. I'm doing that with little quote marks around the foreign. We're very happy about getting new meat on board like turkey. But when it comes to things like tomatoes and potatoes, it's taken centuries of us to get used to them. So how long did it take for us to kind of get to use the potatoes? Because we have a question here from Jordan Carr, who says,
土豆的表亲，是西红柿。我们在英国不太擅长吸收来自外国的蔬菜。我给“外国”加了引号。我们很高兴能吃到像火鸡这样新的肉类。但当谈到西红柿和土豆之类的事情时，我们花了几个世纪才习惯它们。那么我们花了多长时间才开始习惯土豆呢？因为我们这里有一个来自乔丹·卡尔的问题，他说，
my girlfriend, who is Latvian, Russian, and her friend, joked that British food is just made up of different variations of potato dishes and proceeded to laugh at jacket potatoes with beans. I don't see what's wrong with jacket potatoes, except for the beans, actually, which I think is slightly... Rich being criticised for bad food by russians i think by latvians i've heard of i've heard they had potato lacquers yeah um we're quite keen on potatoes but i think they're not the only yeah i think that's i think that is slightly harsh actually because we've've had a long and rather vexed history with potatoes.
我的女朋友是拉脱维亚和俄罗斯混血，她的朋友开玩笑说，英国食物只是土豆菜肴的不同变体，接着他们嘲笑夹心土豆配豆子。我不觉得夹心土豆有什么问题，除了豆子，实际上我觉得稍微有点……被俄罗斯人批评食物不好吃，我觉得，还有拉脱维亚人，我听说过，我听说他们有土豆饼，是的，嗯，我们非常喜欢土豆，但我觉得它们不是唯一的，是的，我觉得这其实有点苛刻，因为我们和土豆有着漫长而相当曲折的历史。
And we've we've come to love them. But I wouldn't say that I wouldn't say that the basis. Oh, gosh. I mean, they were introduced into that. Well, they introduced to Europe, weren't they? From the you know, when the Spanish first went to South and American Central America. So a mere kind of four or 500 years, really. But Penn, do you agree with Jacques Chirac? Are we the worst country after Finland for food? I mean, a lot of our foreign listeners will be laughing at this and saying,
我们已经学会爱上它们了。但我不会说，我不会说那是基础。哦，天哪。我的意思是，它们被引入了。好吧，它们被引入欧洲了，不是吗？从……你知道的，当西班牙人第一次去南美和中美洲时。所以实际上大约只有四五百年。但是彭，你同意雅克·希拉克的观点吗？在芬兰之后，我们的食物是最糟糕的国家吗？我的意思是，我们的很多外国听众会对这一点大笑并说，
of course you are, but they are quite wrong in my view. What do you think? It's so funny. I was in my early 20s. I went to go and teach English in what was then Czechoslovakia. And I thought, you know, I was in the markets of Czechoslovakia.
你当然是，但在我看来他们完全错了。你觉得呢？太有趣了。我二十岁出头的时候。我去当时的捷克斯洛伐克教英语。我以为，你知道的，我在捷克斯洛伐克的市场上。
You couldn't get fresh food anywhere at the time. I'm sure you can now. Everything was kind of fried cheese, pickled cabbage, delicious in its own way. But they all knew for a fact, my students, that English food was the laughing stock of the world. They'd never been to England, they'd never had it, but it was just a fact that they'd kind of learned somewhere. And I think that's a very post-World War II reputation. And really, that late? Yeah, probably. Probably kind of richly deserved, in fact, and all sorts of things kind of got together in World War Two, you know,
当时你到处都买不到新鲜食物。我相信现在可以了。所有的东西基本上都是炸奶酪、腌卷菜，以它们自己的方式很美味。但我的学生们确信，英国食物是全世界的笑柄。他们从来没去过英国，也从来没吃过，但这只是他们不知从哪里学到的一个事实。我认为这是一种非常二战后的声誉。真的，那么晚吗？是的，可能吧。事实上，可能确实是实至名归，各种各样的因素在二战中汇聚在一起，你知道的，
post rationing and all the rest of it to make our food quite bad. But I think it's probably is it harsh? I think it's probably harsh now. Because, you know, all sorts of people, all sorts of gastropubs and chefs have done all kinds of extraordinary things with um you know some kind of english dishes but for a few yeah exactly but for a few decades i think it might have been fair the first raymond postgate when he introduced a good food guide in the 1950s, said, he said, yes, it does look a bit strange. I'm trying to pretend that there is good food in Britain, but you've got to start somewhere. And maybe if we start encouraging people to recommend to each other restaurants that they liked, maybe it will just help us, you know, increase a kind of food culture.
配给制结束后以及所有这些因素导致我们的食物相当糟糕。但我认为这可能，是不是很苛刻？我认为现在可能有点苛刻了。因为，你知道的，各种各样的人，各种各样的美食酒吧和厨师用……你知道的，某种英国菜做出了各种非凡的事情，但几十年来，是的，确切地说，但有几个，我想这可能是公平的。雷蒙德·波斯特盖特在20世纪50年代推出《好食指南》时说，他说，是的，它看起来确实有点奇怪。我正试图假装英国有美食，但你总得从某处开始。也许如果我们开始鼓励人们互相推荐他们喜欢的餐馆，也许这会帮助我们，你知道的，提高一种饮食文化。
Have you read any of those old oh good food guides because i did when i was writing my book on the 80s even in the 80s and a lot of the entries in the 80s i mean these are the good food guides and it would say this is the best restaurant in newcastle don't order the vegetables they're absolutely atrocious or something you know these these descriptions of these it sounds absolutely ghastly and that's kind of how I remember it, actually. 70s, 80s. But, Penny, you think that's because of the war? Because of rationing?
你读过那些旧的《好食指南》吗？因为我写80年代的那本书时读过，甚至在80年代也是如此，80年代的许多条目，我的意思是这些是《好食指南》，上面会写：这是纽卡斯尔最好的餐馆，千万别点蔬菜，它们简直糟透了，诸如此类的话。你知道，这些对它们的描述，听起来简直糟透了。而这其实就是我记忆中的样子，70年代，80年代。但是，彭，你认为那是由于战争吗？因为配给制？
Because the habit of cooking gets broken? Or what happens? Oh, I mean, I think, no, I think when I say post-war, I think we have a very sort of particular post-war diet, which, but I think actually, no, it goes back longer than that. I think if you go right back to kind of where it all went wrong, it is in a way it was probably when because we seem to be going the right way in the kind of long 18th century, that's when the English palette is laid down, when you have female housekeepers who were producing, you know,
因为烹饪的习惯被打断了？还是发生了什么？哦，我的意思是，不，我认为当我说是战后时，我认为我们有一种非常特殊的战后饮食，但是我认为实际上，不，这可以追溯到更早的时候。我认为如果你追溯到一切开始出错的地方，某种程度上它可能是在……因为在漫长的18世纪，我们似乎在朝着正确的方向前进，那是英国人的味蕾确立的时候，当时你有女性管家，她们生产……你知道的，
locally grown, good food, lots of vegetables, lots of meat, always lots of meat. And then I think what really goes wrong is Britain becomes obsessed with kind of social climbing. And one of the ways to socially climb is to have French food. And everything is French food. All the focus goes on French food in that 19th century.
本地种植的优质食物，大量的蔬菜，大量的肉，总是大量的肉。然后我认为真正出错的是英国人开始沉迷于某种向上爬的社会阶层。而实现阶级跃升的方法之一就是吃法国菜。一切都是法国菜。19th世纪的全部焦点都集中在法国菜上。
So it's the fault of the French? No, it's the fault of us trying to be the French. I think we can end the podcast here, can't we? I think we've established it's all... Yeah. No, I think it's the fault of British focus, us trying to kind of imitate French food in a way that just probably didn't suit quite sort of modest English kitchens.
所以这是法国人的错？不，这是我们试图成为法国人的错。我想我们可以把播客停在这里了，不是吗？我想我们已经确定这一切都是……是的。不，我认为这是英国人关注点的错，我们试图模仿法国菜，而这种方式可能根本不适合那些简朴的英国厨房。
So if we could dial it sort of back in time, is there a point at which you can say there is a British cuisine? And if so, when is that point and what is the food? I think if you look at the family dinner that Mrs. Bennett is trying to cook for Darcy and Bingley at the end of Pride and Prejudice. That is probably your British cuisine. And she's very proud of the fact that her venison is really good. The partridges are better than anything that the French chef of Mr. Darcy could produce. She has the right kind of soups. And they're probably made,
所以，如果我们能把时间拨回过去，有没有一个时间点你可以说存在英国菜？如果有，那个时间点是什么时候，食物又是什么？我想如果你看看贝内特太太试图在《傲慢与偏见》结尾为达西和宾利烹饪的家庭晚餐。那可能就是你们的英国菜。她非常自豪于她的鹿肉真的很好。鹧鸪比达西先生的法国厨师做出的任何东西都好。她有正确的汤品。而且它们可能是……
she doesn't say, but they're probably made made of there's probably a fresh pea soup and then a you know a white soup made from chicken or something um and you might have duck and peas a lot often though in those years we do have lots of vegetables but they sort of come with the with the meat and they sort of get forgotten about and hidden so we think so so, aren't there, many of them? But people did eat them. So I think that's probably when it could have got better, you know, from that kind of long 18th century onwards. And somehow the focus just went wrong.
她没有说，但它们可能是由……可能有一道新鲜豌豆汤，然后是一道……你知道的，用鸡肉或其他东西做的白汤，嗯，你可能会有鸭肉和豌豆。不过往往在那些年里，我们确实有很多蔬菜，但它们伴随着肉类出现，然后它们有点被遗忘和隐藏了，所以我们认为……所以，不是有很多吗？但人们确实吃它们。所以我想这大概就是它开始变好的时候，你知道的，从那个漫长的18世纪开始。不知何故，重点就是搞错了。
Thinking about the relationship with France in the 18th into the Regency period, I mean, it is a of british self-congratulation that we eat better that we have roast beef and all the french have is kind of scrawny vegetables yeah yeah there's some kind of amazing passage you quote in the um in the book about was it thackeray saying that that if you got an equal number of Britons fed on beef and Frenchmen fed on Episcene cheese, the plucky Brits would hold the field. He's probably ribbing us, you know, because I think he is sitting in a French restaurant in Paris as he's kind of pontificating about how brilliant British food is.
考虑到18世纪到摄政时期与法国的关系，我的意思是，我们吃得更好、有烤牛肉而法国人只有那种瘦骨嶙峋的蔬菜，这确实是英国人自我吹嘘的一种表现，是的，是的，你在书中引用了一段非常精彩的段落，关于……是萨克雷说的吗，如果你把数量相等的靠牛肉养活的英国人和靠虚弱的奶酪养活的法国人放在一起，勇敢的英国人将坚守阵地。他可能是在拿我们开玩笑，你知道的，因为我认为他正坐在巴黎的一家法国餐厅里，大谈特谈英国食物有多么出色。
Hogarth, that famous cartoon of Data Calais. Yes. But this has to do with beef, isn't it? And that's what's really interesting, is that the 18th century is the point where the roast beef of old England is established. What's all that about? I think it's partly about cows getting bigger.
霍加斯，那幅著名的《加来之门》漫画。是的。但这与牛肉有关，不是吗？这正是真正有趣的地方，18世纪是老英格兰烤牛肉确立的时期。这到底是是怎么回事？我认为这部分是因为牛变得更大了。
It's kind of agricultural revolution and breeders figuring out that you can breed if you can read breed racehorses you can breed livestock and so over about 200 years the weight of cows probably doubled really but i think we've always been quite keen on our beef you know we're beef eaters shakespeare talks about you, beef eating Brits and English rather and all the rest of it. And I think there has been an obsession with and a pride, but an obsession with beef. And like you say, Tom, the on kind of one level, we love to kind of mock the French because their peasants are poor. They can't afford meat. They're having this pathetic soup maker, which is, you know, like a, just a vegetable soup. And actually, at that, you know,
这有点像农业革命和饲养员们发现，如果你能培育赛马，你就能培育家畜，所以在大约200年的时间里，牛的重量可能真的翻了一番。但我认为我们一直对牛肉非常热衷，你知道的，我们是食肉动物，莎士比亚谈到过你们，吃牛肉的英国人和英国人，诸如此类。我认为一直有一种对牛肉的痴迷和骄傲，但也是一种痴迷。就像你说的，汤姆，在某种程度上，我们喜欢嘲笑法国人，因为他们的农民很穷。他们买不起肉。他们只能做这种可悲的汤，你知道的，就像蔬菜汤一样。事实上，在那，你知道的，
in the early 18th century, quite a lot of people thought that English peasants were better fed than French peasants. In the same way that, and you know, obviously, those assumptions change. And now, you know, people think that in France, people are fed better than in England. So what's the role of the Industrial Revolution in that? Because that's another kind of vague idea I had is that we're eating well and the Industrial Revolution comes. And that's what really torpedoes the traditions of British food, because they get lost when people move from the country to the towns. Is that not true? I think it is true, but I think it's probably tangentially true. I think it's partly true because of the enclosures. So when people stop
在18世纪初，相当多的人认为英国农民比法国农民吃得更好。就像，你知道的，很明显，这些假设改变了。现在，你知道的，人们认为在法国，人们比在英国吃得更好。那么工业革命在其中扮演了什么角色呢？因为那是另一个我有的模糊想法，那就是我们吃得很好，然后工业革命来了。这才是真正摧毁英国食品传统的原因，因为当人们从乡村搬到城镇时，它们就失传了。难道不是这样吗？我认为这是真的，但我认为这可能是次要真实的。我认为这部分是因为圈地运动。所以当人们停止
having ground that they can grow food on, that makes it much harder. And you know, that idea of the kind of that we don't have a peasant cuisine in the way that France or other countries have peasant cuisines. I think that partly gets destroyed by the enclosures and all kind of just, you know, picking people up off the land. But I think when you have the industrial revolution, yes, people go into factories. Yes, people go into urban areas. And yes, there are problems of distribution, which, you know, the railways and everything help sort out. But there shouldn't, because there's also a rising middle class, because there's also a rising wealth that should have offset the, you know, the kind of availability. But then the French menus come in.
拥有可以种植食物的土地，这使得事情变得困难得多。你知道那种想法，即我们没有像法国或其他国家那样拥有农民菜系。我认为这部分是被圈地运动摧毁的，而且只是……你知道的，把人们从土地上赶走。但我认为当工业革命爆发时，是的，人们进入了工厂。是的，人们进入了城市地区。是的，存在分销问题，你知道的，铁路和其他一切有助于解决这些问题。但这本不该发生，因为还有一个不断壮大的中产阶级，因为还有不断增长的财富，这本应抵消……你知道的，这种可用性。但接着法国菜单就进来了。
Yeah, but then the french menus come in yeah but then the french menus come in so if you look at something like the way that kind of dickens and his family would would be eating in the 1840s for example horrible detail that you've got about and this this segues very neatly into another theme yeah um her culinary pièce de résistance would be rabbit curry smothered in white sauce yes yes no wonder he ran off. White sauce, yes. Oh, and a curry, yeah. Over a curry, yeah. So no wonder Dickens ran off with Ellen Turner. But food and Dickens, Penny, you've written about food and Dickens a lot.
是的，但接着法国菜单就进来了，是的，但接着法国菜单就进来了，所以如果你看看狄更斯和他的家人在1840年代左右的饮食方式，例如，那些你收集的关于……的可怕细节，而这又非常巧妙地过渡到了另一个主题，是的，嗯，她的拿手好菜将是浸在白酱里的兔肉咖喱，是的，难怪他跑了。白酱，是的。哦，还有咖喱，是的。配上咖喱，是的。难怪狄更斯跟埃伦·特纳私奔了。但食物与狄更斯，彭，你写过很多关于食物与狄更斯的文章。
Dickens's books are full of... So the food they have in Dickens, is that fantasy or is that what people ate at the time, genuinely? I think sometimes it gets a bit Baroque, you know, when he kind of, he has a stew which might have 10 million things in it, including cow heel and, you know, sprue grass, which is asparagus. I think he's pretty much describing what most people would have eaten. And what's interesting about Dickens is it's very unfrench.
狄更斯的书里到处都是……所以狄更斯书里的食物，那是幻想还是当时人们真正吃的？我觉得有时候它有点巴洛克风格，你知道的，当他写到一种可能包含一千万种东西的炖菜时，包括牛蹄和……你知道的，嫩芦笋。我觉得他几乎是在描述大多数人会吃的东西。狄更斯有趣的地方在于它非常不法国化。
He isn't trying to kind of cope with the, you know, the kind of the French menace in his literature, but not in his life. I mean, I guess there are two famous meals, aren't there? There's Oliver Twist asking for more in the workhouse. Yes. And being hungry is kind of the essence of everything that dickens is appalled by because the other famous one is um in christmas carol with scrooge turning up and turkey buying a turkey with a turkey so always acceptable so talk us through about the history of the turkey because that's a really really interesting one one. Well, the turkey was extraordinary. As I say, whenever meat comes, anything kind of meaty comes into this country, everybody adopts it immediately. It comes in the 17th century, the 16th century,
他并不是试图在他的文学作品中应付……你知道的，法国的威胁，但在他的生活中却不是这样。我的意思是，我想有两个著名的餐馆，不是吗？一个是《雾都孤儿》里奥利弗·特斯要求更多食物。是的。挨饿可以说是狄更斯所痛恨的一切的核心，因为另一个著名的是……在《圣诞颂歌》里，斯克鲁奇出现并买了一只火鸡，买了一只火鸡，所以总是可以接受的。那么跟我们讲讲火鸡的历史吧，因为这是一个非常非常有趣的故事。嗯，火鸡太不寻常了。正如我所说，每当肉类到来，任何带肉的东西来到这个国家，每个人都会立即接受它。它在17世纪、16世纪到来，
with a trader called William Strickland. And we don't know exactly the year, but he adopts the image of a turkey on his kind of coat of arms. He's allowed a coat of arms as he becomes kind of more and more ennobled. And when he comes in, there's still this kind of division between landfowl, this idea that if you're a farmyard fowl doesn't quite have the status of meat that you hunt. So, you know, going back to kind of 1066 and William and all this kind of idea of the venison is the best meat,
通过一个名叫威廉·斯特里克兰的商人。我们不知道具体是哪一年，但他在自己的纹章上采用了火鸡的形象。当他越来越受封为贵族时，他被允许拥有纹章。当他出现时，家禽和猎物之间仍然存在这种划分，这种观点认为，如果你是农场家禽，它就没有你捕猎的肉那样的地位。所以，你知道，回到1066年威廉和所有这些关于鹿肉是最好的肉的观点，
it's the most noble meat, and grouse and partridge, anything that you hunt somehow gives you the status of kind of nobility. Whereas if something comes from a farmyard chicken or turkey it has a slightly less status but having said that the turkey is very acceptable to everybody and it comes at a time when the population is growing there probably isn't quite enough meat to go around because the the you know beef hasn't yet done the thing that we were talking about where cows haven't yet kind of doubled in weight and it's very welcome but it comes in such a way where you can you know it's not seen as something which is just kind of for
它是最高贵的肉，还有松鸡和鹧鸪，你捕猎的任何东西不知何故都能赋予你一种贵族的地位。然而，如果某种东西来自农场里的鸡或火鸡，它的地位就会稍微低一点。话虽如此，火鸡对每个人来说都是非常可以接受的，它出现时正值人口增长，可能没有足够的肉来分，因为……你知道的，牛肉还没有做到我们刚才谈到的那种牛的体重还没翻倍的程度，它非常受欢迎。但它的到来方式让你知道（它）不仅仅被视为某种……
the aristocracy so far a farm a farmer might eat it or a kind of small landowner or yeoman. And it gets adopted and it's good in the middle of winter, you know, when there's not much else around and it becomes our kind of our Christmas meat. How big a role does Dickens play in that? I think Dickens, it's always eaten around Christmas, but then meat is always eaten around Christmas. Because they eat beef. Yes. You i eat beef yes i mean yeah you might eat beef around christmas you might eat venison because before before breeders had learned to keep animals alive literally over the winter they had to slaughter most of them in november or december um because otherwise the animals would be competing with us, you know, for very, very sparse kind of cereal and grain resources over the winter.
只属于贵族的东西，一个农民可能会吃它，或者一个小土地拥有者或自耕农。它被接受了，而且在冬天没有什么其他东西的时候它很好吃，你知道的，它成了我们的圣诞肉。狄更斯在其中扮演了多大的角色？我认为狄更斯，它总是在圣诞节前后吃，但肉总是在圣诞节前后吃。因为他们吃牛肉。是的。你吃牛肉，是的，我的意思是，是的，你可能会在圣诞节前后吃牛肉，你可能会吃鹿肉，因为在饲养员学会让动物真正活过冬天之前，他们必须在11月或12月屠宰大部分动物，嗯，否则动物会和我们争夺冬天非常非常稀缺的谷物和粮食资源。
So most animals get eaten around Christmas and turkey. And yeah, Dickens kind of anchors it to the Christmas day. So he has this beautiful description, this brilliant description of, you know, this lovely big turkey and Christmas pudding. But that's the thing that the reformed Scrooge brings him. Whereas the meat they're actually going to have before, you know, before kind of Scrooge sees the light is going to be a goose. I was going to ask about that. Yeah, yeah.
所以大部分动物都在圣诞节前后被吃掉，还有火鸡。是的，狄更斯把它固定在了圣诞节那天。所以他有这个美丽的描述，这个精彩的描述，你知道的，这只可爱的大火鸡和圣诞布丁。但这正是改造后的斯克鲁奇带给他的东西。而他们在看到光明之前真正要吃的肉是一只鹅。我正想问这个呢。是的，是的。
See, to me, a goose is, I had a goose at Christmas. goose at christmas oh lucky you is infinitely superior to turkey in my yeah yeah not not then yeah so why did people so what there was a sort of turn again there was a period wasn't it when the goose kind of dropped out totally i didn't know anyone had a goose in the 70s or the 80s yeah and now the goose has come back as a bit of a status symbol i think so they're quite tricky to cook geese very fatty they're very fatty yeah your whole house knows about it for a few days afterwards i think when you so we had a goose for two of us and when i say two of us me and a nine-year-old because my wife doesn't eat meat so it was incredibly self-indulgent yeah very very satisfying did you carry it back from the market and did an urchin knock your top hat off with a snowball?
看，对我来说，鹅是……我圣诞节吃过鹅。圣诞节吃鹅，哦，你真幸运，在我看来，它比火鸡好得多。是的，是的。当时可不是这样。所以为什么人们……所以有一种转变，有一段时间，不是吗，鹅完全绝迹了？我不认识70年代或80年代有谁吃过鹅。是的，现在鹅作为一种地位的象征又回来了，我想是的。它们很难烹饪，鹅非常油腻。它们非常油腻，是的，你整栋房子都会连续几天闻到这个味道。所以当我们在两个人一起过圣诞时吃了一只鹅，当我说是两个人时，是我和一个九岁的孩子，因为我妻子不吃肉，所以这极其放纵，是的，非常非常满足。你把它从市场上扛回来的吗，有没有一个流浪儿用雪球打掉了你的大礼帽？
Yeah, I got an urchin. I shouted out of the window, what day is it? Christmas Day. Oh, here's a shilling. That's normal life in Chipping Norton, Tom. But actually, what you should have done is done what Mrs. Cratchit did, is send it to the baker to be cooked, because then you wouldn't have all the fattiness in your own house.
是的，我遇到了一个流浪儿。我冲着窗户喊，今天是什么日子？圣诞节！哦，给你一先令。奇平诺顿的日常生活就是这样，汤姆。但实际上，你应该做的是像克拉奇太太那样，把它送到面包店去烤，那样你屋子里就不会有那么多油腻了。
So I've got a question about that. Did people people because you see that a lot in dickens that people will buy a pie and they'll take it to the bakery although yeah so so how does that work if you don't live with the cook if you don't have a big kitchen you take you buy stuff and you send it to a bakehouse and then go and get it because you don't have an oven basically um. You know, the Great Fire of London, probably because everybody had to use massive, not communal ovens, but bakery ovens to cook their things because most people were too poor to afford their own ovens. And you know, pat-a-cake, pat-a-cake, baker's man? Oh, yeah, yeah.
所以我有个问题。人们……因为你在狄更斯的作品中经常看到人们会买一个馅饼然后把它带到面包店去，虽然……是的，所以如果你不住在有厨师的地方，如果你没有一个大厨房，这是怎么运作的？你买东西然后把它送到面包房然后去取，因为你基本上没有烤箱。伦敦大火，可能是因为每个人都必须使用巨大的烤炉——不是社区烤炉，而是烘焙店的烤炉来烤东西，因为大多数人太穷了，买不起自己的烤箱。你知道，“拍个蛋糕，拍个蛋糕，面包师的男人”？哦，对，对。
You know, you prick it with pee because you need to mark it. You need to say, this is my pie. Get off everybody else. Well, Pen, I reckon that's the first course done. So we should take a break and then come back and have the second course. And Pen, I would love to go back to that rabbit curry cooked by Catherine Dickens. Oh, you wouldn't oh you ask you about curry because that also has an intriguing history so we'll come back and we will be talking curry
你知道，你用豌豆刺它，因为你需要标记它。你需要说，这是我的馅饼。别碰别人的。好吧，彭，我想第一道菜完成了。所以我们应该休息一下，然后回来吃第二道菜。彭，我很想回到凯瑟琳·狄更斯做的那个兔肉咖喱。哦，你不会的，哦，我要问你关于咖喱的问题，因为这也有一个引人入胜的历史，所以我们会回来谈论咖喱。
i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、独家加更节目和提前获取现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. With me, Dominic Sandbrook, Tom Holland and our guest, Penn Vogler. And Tom is very keen to talk about curry. Tom, please. Because curry is now basically our national dish, isn't it? And essentially, it's much, much older than I had realised. It's much older, say, than fish and chips. It's much older say than fish and chips. It's older than in Britain yes. Just tell us about about the antiquity of curry and its
欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，和我在一起的有汤姆·霍兰德以及我们的嘉宾彭·沃格勒。汤姆非常热衷于谈论咖喱。汤姆，请吧。因为咖喱现在基本上是我们的国民菜了，不是吗？而且本质上，它比我意识到的要老得多。比方说，它比炸鱼薯条老得多。比方说，它比炸鱼薯条老得多。是的，它比英国还要老。跟我们讲讲咖喱的年代久远以及它
relationship to gravy. Oh yeah so the first recipe for curry in a British cookbook is probably Hannah Glass in 1747 and if you compare it to fish and chips fish and chips didn't get together really as in as a kind of married couple until the probably 1900s but um so hannah glass is writing a recipe for curry it's not that nice to be honest uh it's kind of curry most of the heat comes from white pepper but it's okay i have cooked it yeah i have cooked it but it's interesting because some some of the other things i've cooked and compare it to if you go back to very early um kind of medieval food a lot of that is uh is flavored by the tastes of spices that the crusaders brought back and all the things that we put into curries now, like galangal, you know, ginger, long pepper,
与肉汁的关系。哦，是的，英国食谱中关于咖喱的第一份食谱可能是1747年的汉娜·格拉斯。如果你把它和炸鱼薯条相比，炸鱼薯条真正作为“夫妻档”结合在一起，大概要到1900年代左右。但是，汉娜·格拉斯写了一份咖喱食谱，说实话，它不是那么好吃……咖喱的大部分辣味来自白胡椒，但还可以，我做过，是的，我做过。但这很有趣，因为我做过的一些其他东西，如果你追溯到非常早期的中世纪食物，其中很多都是……带有十字军东征带回来的香料的味道，以及我们现在放入咖喱中的所有东西，比如高良姜、生姜、长胡椒、
you know, black pepper and all that stuff, not chilli, obviously, because that's a New World thing. They were being used and enjoyed by our kind of wealthier medieval forebears. So a curry is kind of closer to the tastes of English medieval food than fish and chips. Yes. Oh, yes, I think so. I mean, I think English medieval food is a little bit,
你知道，黑胡椒和所有这些东西，显然没有辣椒，因为那是新大陆的东西。我们的富裕中世纪祖先一直在使用和享用它们。所以咖喱在口味上有点类似于英国中世纪的食物，而不是炸鱼薯条。是的。哦，是的，我想是的。我的意思是，我认为英国中世纪的食物有点……介于咖喱和北非塔吉锅之间。你知道，某种程度上它更偏向酸甜口。但其中一些中世纪食谱确实感觉相当现代，与汉娜·格拉斯的咖喱不同。但汉娜·格拉斯烹饪的时代，许多人为英国……你知道的，东印度公司工作，去印度，爱上了这种神奇的食物，并希望在回国后也能品尝到它，人们在咖啡馆里出售咖喱粉，并从1700年代早期左右开始推广咖喱的概念。我想就你刚才说的一点请教你，也就是关于中世纪烹饪的……我的意思是，这太迷人了，那……我的意思是，很明显我们
it's a little bit halfway between a curry and sort of North African tagines. You know, it's a little bit more sweet and sour in a way. But some of those, you know, medieval recipes do feel quite contemporary, unlike Hannah Glass's curry. But Hannah Glass was cooking at a time when a lot of people were working for the British, you know, the East Indian company, going to India, falling in love with this amazing food and wanting to taste it back home and people were selling curry powder in kind of coffee shops and just starting to kind of roll out the idea of curry from about the sort of early early eight seventeen hundreds. Can I pick you up on something you just said which is about the medieval cooking being I mean that's fascinating that that the sort of I mean obviously we're
谈论的是最高层的人，我假设是这样。绝对是最高层。所以他们迷人的地方在于，我的意思是，很明显我们谈论的是最高层的人，我假设是这样。绝对是最高层，是的。所以他们吃的是一种……你知道的，介于咖喱和摩洛哥塔吉锅之类的东西之间。但问题是，在哪个时间点这退出了方程式呢？为什么英国食物会获得这种缺乏香料的清淡名声，而显然它在1400年或1500年或任何时候是非常有滋有味的？我认为……内战可能……如果你想要一个能给我们最好的内战……你知道的，最好注解的点的话，可能是内战。因为清教徒非常反对香料，他们非常反对……你知道的……他们称之为“可恶的生长物”，这可能是一种加了香料的水果浓汤。
talking about people at the top I assume. Right at the top. So what they're fascinating that the sort of, I mean, obviously we're talking about people at the top, I assume. Right at the top, yes. So what they're eating is a sort of, you know, somewhere between a curry and, you know, Moroccan tagine or something. But the question then is, at what point does that fall out of the equation? So why does British food acquire this reputation for unspiced blandness when clearly it was very spicy in 1400 or 1500 or whenever i think um the civil war probably um is probably if you want one point that probably gives us the best civil you know the best point because the puritans were very against spice they were very against kind of you know uh this what they called an abominable growth, which is probably a kind of potage of spiced fruit.
他们基本上认为那是教皇派的。他们认为那是教皇派的。他们认为这基本上是浪费钱，我想。穷人应该把他们辛苦挣来的钱花在像样的东西上。我不知道，面包和啤酒之类的。面包和肉。水。面包和水和肉。水。面包和水。
They thought it was papist, basically. They thought it was papist. They thought it was basically a waste of money, I think. The poor should be spending their hard-earned money on something decent. I don't know, bread and beer or something. Bread and meat. Water. Bread and water and meat water bread and water
是的，或者……你知道的，面包和圣经或清教徒的小册子，你知道的，比如《飞鹰》或诸如此类的小册子。但是在那之后……而且我认为，但这不仅是因为清教徒，我还认为……口味正在改变，因为就像你说的，在都铎时期，只有非常非常高层 的家庭在决定菜单，当你有了中产阶级——我猜当你有了这种开始壮大的中产阶级时，掌控菜单的人往往是女性，她可能是一个管家，她可能会更多地在本地寻找食物，而不是昂贵的香料。彭，当……小猪公鸡是什么时候……多米尼克，你熟悉小猪公鸡吗？好吧，我可能已经把它从我的记忆中抹去了。好吧，我谷歌了一下，我希望……我希望我没有……公鸡是有点像土克鸭吗？是的，是的，有点像……顺序组合而不是……所以你得到了一只公鸡的前半部分。对。
yeah or or you know bread and bibles or puritanical tracts you know like the flying eagle or whatever they're called um but after and i think but it's partly it's not just the puritans i think also it is that um tastes are changing because like like you said, in the kind of Tudor period, it was the very, very kind of top families who were just determining that kind of when you get the middling sort I suppose when you get this kind of middle class that begins to grow up and it tends to be the person who's in control is the menu is probably female she's probably a housekeeper and she's probably going to look around her much more locally for food than kind of expensive spices. Pen when when do cocker pigs are you familiar with the cocker pig dominic well i i've probably i've erased that from my memory well i googled it and i wish i wish that i had a cock is it a bit like a turducken yes yes a bit a bit sequential rather than yeah so you get you get the front of a cock. Right. Cockerel. Nice.
小公鸡。不错。是的。然后你把它粘在小猪的后半部分上。或者反过来。或者反过来。是的。彭，你尝试过这个吗？你做过吗？因为那是理查二世最喜欢的食物，不是吗？
Yes. And you stick it onto the back of a small pig. Or the other way around. Or the other way around. Yes. Have you tried that, Ben? Have you cooked that? Because that was Richard II's favourite food, wasn't it?
而且他会……上菜时镀金。带金箔。是的，是的。我真的很想尝尝。好吧，他们是怎么做到的呢？所以他们会有一个大托盘什么的，上面有公鸡的前半部分和猪的后半部分。更有可能是猪的前半部分和母鸡或公鸡的后半部分之类的。
And he'd have... Serve it gilded. Come with a gold leaf. Yes, yes. I really, really want to try that. Well, how do they do that? So they'd have a big tray or something, and they'd have the front of a cock and the back of a pig. More likely the front of a pig and the back of a hen or cock or something.
然后他们把它缝上去。哇。这就像《印第安纳琼斯与魔宫传奇》里的东西。但这又是清教徒毁掉的另一件事吗？是的，我觉得那相当……在中世纪最高档的餐桌上，他们喜欢看起来与众不同的东西。你知道，他们喜欢展示和看起来奇怪的东西。
And they'd sew it on. Wow. That's like something from Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom. But is that another thing the Puritans ruined? Yeah, I think that's quite... In the kind of the most kind of highest tables in medieval times, they loved things that just looked different. You know, they loved kind of display and things to look odd.
所以他们实际上真的会喜欢，你知道的，赫斯顿·布鲁门塔尔做他的肉果东西。肉果，是的。我认为肉果起源于中世纪。所以实际上，因为我曾想过他是不是把这个推得太远了，但听起来他根本没有。事实上，他走得还不够远。我认为他的食谱实际上是基于他发现的食谱。
So they would actually really like, you know, Heston Blumenthal does his meat fruit things. Meat fruit, yes. I think meat fruit comes from medieval. So actually that, because I wondered whether he was pushing that a bit too far, but it doesn't sound like he is at all. Actually, he's not going far enough. I think his recipes are based on recipes that he's found, actually.
但他们喜欢东西看起来像刺猬或者……而且在当时那会是一种国际化的品味吗？我的意思是，如果是端给国王的，想必这些都是皇家餐桌上发生的浮夸事情，在我们基督教世界的大部分地方，是的，我认为我们很多最高端的品味在当时都来自意大利或西班牙。你知道，冰淇淋等东西进入这个国家时是通过西班牙，然后是意大利。是的，西班牙，然后是意大利，然后来到这里，巧克力、咖啡，所有这些东西我们都是从那里吸收的。你认为英国是一个岛屿，我们曾派船只驶向世界各地，这一事实对我们的品味模式有多大影响？我们的国家菜系在很大程度上受到世界各地影响的塑造，这很不寻常吗？我认为我们非常具有吸收能力。我们非常擅长做的一件事是接受某些口味，比如茶，
But they love things to kind of look like hedgehogs or um and that would be an international taste at that time would i mean if it's being served to the king presumably these are the kind of flamboyant things that are going on on royal tables a lot of our christendom yeah i think a lot of our kind of our highest tastes come from either Italy or Spain at that time. You know, things like ice cream when they kind of come into this country come via Spain, then Italy. Yeah, Spain, then Italy and then up here, chocolate, coffee, all those things we kind of absorb from there. And do you think the fact that Britain's an island and we have sent ships around the world, how influential has that been on the patterns of our taste? Are we unusual to the degree that our national cuisine is kind of shaped by influences from across the world? I think we are very absorptive. What we're quite good at doing is taking some tastes like tea,
例如，将它们“英国化”或本土化。茶，可可也是如此。所以如果你看看茶，你知道的，它最初是在中国种植的。我们与中国的贸易有点零星。它相当不可靠。所以有人不得不去中国偷一些茶的种子和植物，把它们种在印度优质的英国（加引号）种植园里。这就是印度的，你知道的，茶种植园腾飞的时候。是的，然后它推动了英属印度的崛起、美国革命和法国革命。但关于茶的问题，彭，毫无疑问，我认为这个悬在许多世界历史之上的问题是，
for example, and kind of British-britishifying them or anglicising it. Tea, cocoa is the same. So if you look at tea, you know, it first was grown in China. Our trade with China was a bit patchy. It was quite unreliable. And so somebody had to go and steal some seeds and some plants of tea from China and plant them in good British, in inverted commas, plantations in India. And that's when the Indian, you know, kind of tea plantation takes off. Yeah, and then it kind of powers the rise of the Raj and the American Revolution and the French Revolution. But the question with tea though, Penn, surely, the question that I think hangs over so much world history,
美国的建国故事是关于茶的，是的，把茶扔进港口。美国是英国这个伟大的饮茶国家的衍生品，然而正如我们所有的听众所知道的，你去美国这个奇妙、充满活力、富裕的国家，却根本不可能喝到一杯像样的茶。我认为这是一种政治拒绝，他们有着漫长的政治记忆。我不知道，我不知道为什么，你知道的，我认为当你要求一杯茶时，他们给你一个茶包和一杯热水——如果幸运的话是温的——让你自己泡，是的，还有柠檬。
America's founding story is about tea yes throwing tea into the harbour america is an offshoot of britain this great tea drinking nation and yet as all our listeners will know you go to america this fantastic dynamic rich country and it is simply impossible to get a proper cup of tea i think it's a political repudiation they have long political memories i don't know i have no idea why you know i think when you ask for a cup of tea and they give you a tea bag and a cup of hot water warm if you're lucky make it yourself yes and lemon yeah the lemon that's just poncified isn't it dominic don't go broad it's a terrible mistake no i mean i i go i genuinely do you know can you i mean this is i'm not even exaggerating this for That's just poncified, isn't it? Dominic, don't go abroad. It's a terrible mistake. No, I mean, I genuinely...
那个柠檬太矫情了，不是吗，多米尼克？别扯远了，这是一个可怕的错误。不，我的意思是，我真的……我的意思是，我甚至不是为了播客的效果而夸大其词。那个柠檬太矫情了，不是吗，多米尼克？别扯远了，这是一个可怕的错误。不，我的意思是，我真的……
I mean, I'm not even exaggerating this for the purposes of the podcast. I genuinely take tea bags when I go on holiday. I mean, my wife thinks it's ludicrous, but we always travel now with colossal quantities of tea. Have you come across biscuit tea? No. What's biscuit tea?
我的意思是，我甚至不是为了播客的效果而夸大其词。我度假时真的会带茶包。我的意思是，我妻子觉得这很荒谬，但我们现在旅行总是带着大量的茶。你遇到过饼干茶吗？没有。什么是饼干茶？
It's the single greatest British cultural achievement since Sgt Pepper. Is it tea in the form of a biscuit? Yorkshire tea, and it's just a hint of a biscuit. Yeah, you get a hint of biscuit in my house by dipping your biscuit in the tea. So is that like you've dipped your biscuit in the tea and you've left it a bit too long and it's kind of crumbled into the tea? Yeah. So whenever I despair of Britain, I have brewed myself a cup of that and wow all my confidence in the country is restored i want before we get into the questions from the audience
这是自《佩珀军士》以来最伟大的英国文化成就。它是饼干形状的茶吗？约克郡茶，它只有一丝饼干的香味。是的，你在我家可以通过把饼干蘸到茶里来获得一丝饼干味。所以这就像你把饼干蘸进茶里，然后放得太久，它在茶里碎掉了？是的。所以每当我为英国感到绝望时，我就会给自己泡上一杯那个，哇，我对这个国家的所有信心都恢复了。在听众提问之前，
i also want to ask pen a question about pies what is it about britain and pies because i think the pie is that great culinary achievement obviously the pie is very unfashionable now which is sad to me anyway but why are we so good at pies compared with other people they don't really have them do they john bull asks i don't know why we're so good and compared with other people but uh we are good at pies and i think um probably because partly because we've always been good at meat and a pie sticking a bit of meat in a pie is a good way for it not to dry out you know if you're going to put it in the oven if it's going to be massive so hannah glass her she of the early curry recipe has this recipe for a yorkshire pie and that's where this myth of the
我还想问彭一个关于馅饼的问题。英国和馅饼之间到底有什么渊源？因为我认为馅饼是伟大的烹饪成就，显然现在馅饼非常不流行，这对我来说很悲伤，但为什么与其他国家的人相比，我们这么擅长做馅饼？他们真的没有，对吧？约翰·布尔问。我不知道为什么我们这么擅长，与其他国家的人相比，但……我们确实擅长做馅饼，而且我认为，可能是因为部分原因是我们一直擅长做肉，在馅饼里塞上一块肉是防止它变干的好方法，你知道的，如果你要把肉放进烤箱，如果它会很大。所以汉娜·格拉斯——她那位早期咖喱食谱的作者——有这个约克郡馅饼的食谱，这就是土克鸭神话的来源，因为实际上——我没有见过那种食谱，但她确实有火鸡，里面是鸭子，里面是阉鸡，里面是鹧鸪的血或其他什么，都在一个馅饼里，而且自始至终都有填料，所以当你切开它时，你应该有很好的小彩层，你知道的，你可能会有一个绿色的填料，一个红色的填料——所以这样可以把它放进烤箱，并且能保持所有的水分，你知道的，防止它变干。所以我们早期的馅饼，就像我们早期的肉馅饼一样，你可能会有一个鹿肉馅饼，它们可能是用非常坚固的黑麦面粉做的，相当重。你会把它堵上，做好肉馅饼，让它冷却，用黄油封口。
turk duck and comes from because that's actually i haven't seen a recipe for that but she does have the turkey and then inside it the duck and then inside it the capon and then inside it the blood of partridge or whatever and that's in a pie and that's it and with stuffing all the way through so when you cut into it you should have nice kind of little colored layers you know you might have a green stuffing a red stuffing so and that would keep you could put it in the oven and you'd keep it all, you know, you'd keep it from drying out. And so our early pies, like our early pasties, you might have a venison pasty and they might be made with really solid rye flour, pretty heavy. You'd plug it, you'd make your pasty, let it cool, plug it with butter.
就像一个罐头，所以，你知道的，为了把空气隔绝在外。而且它可以保存很久。但你甚至可能不吃外皮。它可能太硬太结实了，但你仍然能吃到中间的那块鹿肉。所以我们把馅饼部分用作储物罐。而且你可以把它们装饰得很漂亮。就像在康沃尔郡一样。像在什么地方，康沃尔郡？
So like a tin, so, you know, to keep the air out. And it would keep for ages. But you might not even eat the pastry. It might be just too hard and too solid, but you'd still have the bit of venison left in the middle. And so we used pies partly as a kind of a storage jar. And you can decorate them beautifully. Like in Cornwall. Like in what, Cornwall?
所以就像一个罐头，你知道的，为了隔绝空气。而且可以保存很久。但你可能根本不会吃外面的面皮。它可能太硬、太结实了，不过中间的那块鹿肉还在。所以我们把派在某种程度上当作了一种储藏罐。而且你可以把它装饰得很漂亮。就像在康沃尔一样。像在哪里，康沃尔？
Like in Cornwall. Yeah, exactly. Pasty. and you can decorate them beautifully you know there's early like in what cornwall yeah exactly exactly the cornish pasty whatever that used to be well didn't pasta used to have different opacity was a whole meal wasn't it jam at one end and vegetables and stuff at the other isn't that right and tin miners had them yeah but opacity can be anything you know there's i've got this lovely uh book that i talk about in my book. It's the Cornish Federation of Women's Institutes. And in 1934, they poll all their members and get them to send in their pasty recipes. And you might have a rabbit pasty or a windy pasty.
就像康沃尔那样。对，完全是这样。康沃尔肉馅饼。你知道，你可以把它们装饰得很漂亮，就像在什么康沃尔那样，完全是这样。康沃尔肉馅饼，不管以前是什么样的。嗯，以前的肉馅饼不是有不同的馅料吗？这是一顿完整的饭，不是吗？一头是果酱，另一头是蔬菜之类的东西，对不对？锡矿工吃过这种馅饼。不过，肉馅饼可以是任何东西，你知道的，我有一本可爱的书，我在我的书中谈到了它。那是康沃尔女子协会联合会。在1934年，他们调查了所有的成员，让他们把肉馅饼的食谱寄过来。你可能会有一个兔子肉馅饼或是一个温迪肉馅饼。
And I can't quite remember what that is. Yeah, a windy pasty. Yeah, it's probably spinach or something and you might put dates in it you might put herring in it but what you but herring herring on the topic of pat of herring here's quite and it's a topical one bearing in mind um the the brexit agreements about fish casper asked why does fish play such a small role and has it always been like that so we're surrounded by fish we're surrounded by sea we have so many rivers it's probably because fish was popish you know fish yeah probably
我记不太清那是什么了。对，温迪肉馅饼。是的，里面可能是菠菜之类的，你可能会在里面放枣子，也可能会放鲱鱼。但说到鲱鱼，在鲱鱼这个话题上，这挺有意思的，而且也是个热门话题，考虑到关于鱼类的脱欧协议。卡斯珀问，为什么鱼类扮演的角色这么小，而且一直都是这样吗？我们周围都是鱼，我们周围都是海，我们有那么多的河流，这可能是因为鱼曾被视为天主教色彩的食物，你知道的，鱼，是的，可能是。
before the often it was probably a protestant, before the Reformation, you had these enforced fast days where you couldn't eat meat or milk or eggs. And about, in really early medieval time, about a third of your year or more, you know, if you were in the church or particularly holy, you'd be on a fast day. But fish, or they might, they were sometimes called fish days and flesh days. So if you were fasting, in inverted commas, you might be able to eat fish because it was allowed. And I think fasting wasn't very popular. When you get to the Reformation, it's a very confusing time for people. They don't know what they're allowed to eat. So on the whole, they decide that they're going to eat meat rather than fish.
在宗教改革之前，通常可能是一个新教徒，在宗教改革之前，有这种强制的斋戒日，在这一天你不能吃肉、牛奶或鸡蛋。大约在非常早的中世纪时期，大约三分之一或更多的年份里，如果你在教会里或者特别虔诚，你就会处于斋戒日。但是鱼，或者他们有时被称为鱼日和肉日。所以如果你在斋戒，加引号的斋戒，你也许可以吃鱼，因为这是被允许的。而且我认为斋戒不是很受欢迎。当你到了宗教改革时期，对人们来说这是一个非常混乱的时期。他们不知道自己被允许吃什么。所以在总体上，他们决定吃肉而不是吃鱼。
Thanks very much, because that's a bit popish. Also, I think a lot of our fish was salted. So you'd have had salted fish, salted codfish. I've got one recipe for codfish from the 14th century that says beat it for an hour to tenderise it. It didn't have the greatest reputation. And I think people just kind of use this as an excuse to kind of veer towards meat because meat is the status thing. We're all pretty upset. You know, we're pretty obsessed by status
非常感谢，因为那有点天主教色彩。此外，我认为我们的很多鱼都是盐腌的。所以你会吃咸鱼，咸鳕鱼。我有一份14世纪的鳕鱼食谱，上面说要把它捶打一个小时来让它变嫩。它的名声不太好。而且我认为人们只是把这当作一个借口，倾向于吃肉，因为肉是身份的象征。我们所有人都很不高兴。你知道的，我们对身份非常着迷
and meat means you've got money or land to show that status. Since we're talking about status, maybe we should talk about class because it plays such a huge part in your book. So let's get into dinner, tea, supper. Oh, yes. Now, I was brought up,
肉意味着你有钱或有土地来展示这种地位。既然我们在谈论地位，也许我们应该谈谈阶级，因为它在你的书中占了很大比重。所以让我们来谈谈正餐、下午茶和晚餐。哦，是的。现在，我是被抚养长大的，
I think my parents said lunch and dinner kind of interchangeably for the midday, mid sort of meal, and then tea in the evening. I suppose a lot of children would have tea in the evening because that scene is slightly infantilising, isn't it, to have tea, I suppose. But Tom is very much a supper man, which I regard as foppish.
我想我的父母对午餐和晚餐的说法是可以互换的，用来指代中午或白天的某种餐食，然后在晚上吃茶点。我想很多小孩子都会在晚上吃茶点，因为吃茶点在视觉上有点幼稚，不是吗？我想是的。但汤姆是个彻头彻尾的晚餐迷，在我看来，这有点矫揉造作。
Yeah. I am a fop. I'm not going to apologise for it. Where do you, what's your position? I mean, you must, I know you're trying to be an objective observer, but you must have a personal position on this, as well as a historian's one. Well, my position is middle class northerner so
是的。我就是个矫情的人。我不会为此道歉。你呢，你的立场是什么？我的意思是，你一定，我知道你试图做一个客观的观察者，但作为一个历史学家，你对这个问题一定也有个人的立场。嗯，我的立场是一个中产阶级北方人，所以
my position which is probably why i'm so interested in class anyway because when i grew up my parents had lunch in the middle of the day and we had tea when we were kids but then dinner as we were older in the evening but none of my friends at school did they all had dinner in the middle of the day we went to yorkshire schools you know i went to school in leeds so we had dinner ladies and school dinners um and then we would have dinner in the evening we kind of didn't see any no two dinners yeah you have two dinners what's not to love yeah you're like a hobbit with their two breakfasts but but you know the the meal that's uncontroversial is breakfast. Yes, it's the only one.
我的立场，这可能就是为什么我对阶级这么感兴趣的原因，因为当我长大时，我父母在中午吃午餐，我们小时候吃茶点，但长大后我们在晚上吃晚餐。不过我在学校的朋友都不是这样，他们都在中午吃晚餐。我们上的是约克郡的学校，你知道的，我在利兹上学，所以我们有午餐女士和学校晚餐，嗯，然后在晚上我们会吃晚餐，我们好像没看到任何……等等，两顿晚餐？对，你吃两顿晚餐，这有什么不好的？是的，你就像霍比特人一样吃了两顿早餐。但是你知道，毫无争议的一餐是早餐。是的，它是唯一的一餐。
We have a question from Richard Banks, which I know you're going to be able to answer, which is when did the full English breakfast first appear and what did it include? But let's just break that. When did the elements of the full English breakfast start to appear? Well, the elements have probably always been there, but they've been in different parts of either the British Isles or different parts of the world. So the world, you know, if you're talking about kedgeree, for example, which was a very kind of Victorian breakfast,
我们有一个来自理查德·班克斯的问题，我知道你一定能回答，那就是全套英式早餐是什么时候首次出现的？它包括什么？但让我们先剖析一下。全套英式早餐的元素是什么时候开始出现的？嗯，这些元素可能一直都在，但它们存在于不列颠群岛的不同地区或世界不同地区。所以，世界，你知道的，如果你谈论的是吉久里（一种咖喱饭菜），例如，那是非常具有维多利亚时代特色的早餐，
but the things like, you know, your black pudding and your sausages and particular ways of kind of doing eggs or something. Some of those are, and porridge, obviously, some of those come from Scotland, Wales. And they were kind of brought together with some of the best kind of elements of the home farm, your home produce, on the Edwardian country house table. So this idea that the full English breakfast has this really long history is probably not true. You might have a full Scottish breakfast, you know.
但是像黑布丁、香肠以及做鸡蛋的特定方式之类的东西。其中一些是，还有粥，显然，其中一些来自苏格兰、威尔士。它们在爱德华时代的乡村庄园餐桌上，与家庭农场、你的农产品中最好的元素结合在一起。因此，全套英式早餐有着非常悠久历史的这种想法可能是不正确的。你可能会吃全套苏格兰早餐，你知道的。
I've got Sir Kenelm Digby. Oh, yes, of course. He likes collops and eggs, doesn't he? Two punched eggs. Yes, with collops and pure bacon are not bad for breakfast. They're not bad for breakfast. So that's 17th century, surely. 17th century.
我有肯纳姆·迪格比爵士的书。哦，是的，当然。他喜欢带肉片和鸡蛋的早餐，不是吗？两个水煮蛋。是的，带肉片和纯培根的早餐还不错。它们作为早餐还不错。所以那是17世纪的，毫无疑问。17世纪。
That is 17th century. Because he invented the wine bottle, didn't he? As well, I think. Yes, yes, yes. He was a great inventor. That's true. That's true. But if you talk about that, I would just say that was B and E. But if you're talking about the full English, the seven deadly sins, the kind of groaning plate, you know. The Costa del Sol, as I actually think. I mean, there was so much in your book that kind of made me salivate. But this was one I particularly noted. And it was somebody called George Borough in 1862. Oh, yeah.
那是17世纪的。因为他发明了酒瓶，不是吗？我想也是。是的，是的，是的。他是个伟大的发明家。这是真的。这是真的。但如果你谈论这个，我只会说那是培根和鸡蛋。但如果你谈论的是全套英式早餐，七宗罪，那满满一大盘，你知道的。太阳海岸，我实际上是这么认为的。我的意思是，你的书中有很多内容让我垂涎三尺。但这是我特别注意到的一点。这是一个叫乔治·伯勒的人在1862年写的。哦，是的。
In Wales. Wild Wales. Pot of hair. Ditto of trout. Pot of prepared shrimps. Dish of plain shrimps. Tins of sardines. Beautiful beefsteak.
在威尔士。狂野的威尔士。一壶发胶？哦不，一壶野味。一盘鳟鱼。一罐调制好的虾。一盘普通虾。一罐沙丁鱼。美味的牛排。
Eggs. Muffin. Large loaf. Butter. Not forgetting capital T. There's a breakfast. there is a breakfast for you when did that go out of fashion i mean that sounds amazing yeah why has it gone out of fashion i think we've got very focused on very specific uh
鸡蛋。松饼。大面包。黄油。别忘了大写的茶。这就是早餐。这才是真正给你的早餐。那个是什么时候过时的？我的意思是，听起来太棒了。是的，为什么它过时了？我想我们变得非常关注非常具体的
um elements of the breakfast it's a bit like the afternoon tea as soon as it starts becoming a thing that cafes or hotels offer it has to become much more straightforward for them because it's it's just too difficult isn't it for most kind of cafes and hotels to offer all that stuff when you sort of read about people having steak at breakfast i mean they'd have a lot of breakfast wouldn't they you never see that now generally unless you were having something incredibly extravagant or pork bones you know pork uh ribs and boiled eggs or something yeah but i think on the whole before that kind of edwardian breakfast i suppose or kind of late victorian breakfast you might have a big old solid breakfast if you were traveling or going off to go hunting for the
嗯，早餐的元素。这有点像下午茶，一旦它开始成为咖啡馆或酒店提供的一项特色服务，对他们来说就必须变得更加简单直接，因为对于大多数咖啡馆和酒店来说，提供所有这些东西实在太难了，不是吗？当你读到人们在早餐时吃牛排的时候，我的意思是，他们会吃很多早餐，不是吗？你现在基本看不到这种现象了，除非你吃一些极其奢侈的东西，或者猪骨头，你知道的，猪肋骨和水煮蛋之类的东西。是的，但我觉得总的来说，在那类爱德华时代早餐之前，或者说晚期维多利亚时代的早餐，如果你在旅行或者去打猎，你可能会吃一顿丰盛扎实的早餐，
day or working for the day but on the whole whole, most people would just eat bread, toast, cake, maybe, you know, pound cake or something like that. If you were very grand, you might eat French bread, which was more like a brioche. It was kind of enriched with egg and butter and quite delicious, really. When I went on my French exchange, I was dumbstruck to find them drinking beer at breakfast. Oh, that's very interesting.
或者为一天的工作做准备，但总的来说，大多数人只会吃面包、吐司、蛋糕，也许还有磅蛋糕之类的东西。如果你非常高贵，你可能会吃法式面包，它更像是一种奶油面包。它富含鸡蛋和黄油，真的很美味。当我参加法国交换生项目时，我惊呆了，发现他们在早餐时喝酒。哦，这非常有趣。
Which I thought was just wrong. But that's what they did in Shakespeare's time, isn't it? Yeah, well, that's what I was going to say. At what point did we stop having alcohol so early? Or indeed, as a sort of standard drink. Unless you're in an airport. Yeah, exactly. The quick trip to Wetherspoons. I think there's an overlap with tea.
我觉得这太离谱了。但莎士比亚时代的人就是这么做的，不是吗？是的，好吧，这就是我要说的。我们是从什么时候开始停止那么早喝酒的？或者实际上把它作为一种标准饮料。除非你在机场。对，完全是这样。去韦瑟斯poons酒吧的快闪之旅。我认为这与茶有重叠。
And, you know, you'd have to have alcohol. Before you had tea and you didn't know that boiling water would make your water safe, unless you had a very safe well, you know, a well where you knew the water was really pure, you'd have to have alcohol. You know, it'd be called small beer because you'd press everything twice and the first lot would be kind of big, you know, not big beer, but ale with a bit of a heft to it.
而且，你知道的，你必须喝酒。在你喝茶之前，你并不知道把水烧开会让水变得安全，除非你有一个非常安全的水井，你知道的，一个你知道水真的很纯净的水井，否则你必须喝酒。你知道的，这被称为淡啤酒，因为你会把所有东西压榨两次，第一轮的酒精度会比较高，不是高度啤酒，而是有点分量的麦芽酒。
And the second lot would be small beer, so it might have half a percent or one percent alcohol. But people knew that it was safe to drink. Do you think there'd be a market for you know a restaurant providing that welsh breakfast obsessed with that welsh breakfast yeah but but combine that with beer small beer yeah do you know something i think i think and this is my my my first post-lockdown uh voyage i think that uh hotel or pub still exists actually does it in in? In Ballard, in Wales, yes.
而第二轮就是淡啤酒，所以它的酒精含量可能只有百分之零点五或百分之一。但人们知道它是安全的。你觉得会有一个市场，你知道的，有一家餐厅提供那种威尔士早餐吗？对那种威尔士早餐着迷？是的，但是把这个和啤酒结合起来，淡啤酒。你知道吗，我觉得，这是我的第一次封锁后的旅行，我觉得那家酒店或酒吧实际上仍然存在。真的吗？在威尔士的巴拉，是的。
I'm quite tempted by that. Whether it does or not, I'm not sure. Whether it serves that breakfast, I don't know. So to move to something much more austere for a second, almost depressingly austere and sort of very lockdown-ish, Carrot of Fire has a question. Yeah, it's a great question. It's a great name.
我对那个很感兴趣。它是否存在，我不确定。它是否提供那样的早餐，我不知道。所以，为了暂时转向一些更加简朴的东西，几乎是令人沮丧的简朴，非常像封锁时期的感觉，“火之胡萝卜”有一个问题。是的，这是一个很好的问题。这是一个很好的名字。
It says Tom and Dominic, but I think this question's open to you as well, since you're on the programme. Could you elaborate on the origins of the sandwich? And that is a good question, because it's not really invented by the Earl of Sandwich, is it? Is that just a myth?
它说汤姆和多米尼克，但我觉得这个问题对你也开放，既然你在节目里的话。你能详细说说三明治的起源吗？这是一个很好的问题，因为三明治并不是伯爵真正发明的，对吧？这只是个神话吗？
Well, a myth with some truth in it. I mean, I think the myth bit about the Earl of Sandwich is that he was a gamer because his biographer says that he actually worked apart, that needs a really sharp knife to cut it well. It needs something to cut the middle stuff well to put it together. So actually, people would have been eating those component parts in the fields, agricultural workers, you know, just forever. But they'd have never called, it wouldn't have been a sandwich, they'd have had a hunk of, you know, a hunk of bread and a crust of bread and something else in their hands. So I don't know if he invented it, but he definitely popularised it. I think it's probably safe to say.
嗯，这是一个带有部分真实性的神话。我的意思是，我认为关于三明治伯爵神话的部分在于他是一个赌徒，因为他的传记作家说他实际上是分开工作的，切好它需要一把非常锋利的刀。它需要一些东西来把中间的东西切好放在一起。事实上，农业工人在田里一直都在吃这些组成部分。但他们从来不叫它，它不会是三明治，他们手里会有一大块面包、面包皮和其他东西。所以我不知道是不是他发明的，但他绝对将其普及了。我想这样说大概是安全的。
So that's a historical myth that's true. Yeah. That's great. But before we do that, can I ask one more question? Yes. Can I jump in one more question? If there's one thing from the past that you would like to bring back as a staple you know not as a treat but as something that we don't eat enough of that we used to eat what would it be cock a pig surely yeah for breakfast yeah i think it's
所以这是一个真实存在的历史神话。是的。这太棒了。但在我们做那个之前，我能再问一个问题吗？可以。我能插话再问一个问题吗？如果有一件过去的东西你想把它作为主食带回来，你知道的，不是作为一种享受，而是作为一种我们吃得不够多、而我们过去常常吃的东西，那会是什么？“考克·阿·皮格”（一种传统鸡肉培根馅饼），肯定的。是的，作为早餐。是的，我觉得
probably mutton um it's slightly odd how we've moved away from mutton. We're obsessed. Well, we're not actually even obsessed enough with lamb. You know, we have however many sheep, 36 million sheep in these isles, and we're not actually eating that much lamb. But we seem never to eat mutton any longer. But the New York Times says we do. Yeah. The New York Times said that all we do is eat mutton.
可能是羊肉吧。我们对羊肉的疏远有点奇怪。我们很着迷。好吧，其实我们对羊肉甚至还不够着迷。你知道的，我们有许许多多的羊，这个岛上有3,600万只羊，而我们实际上并没有吃那么多羊肉。但我们似乎再也不吃羊肉了。但《纽约时报》说我们吃了。是的。《纽约时报》说我们所做的一切就是吃羊肉。
Well, they were running some ludicrous story, weren't they, saying British cooking has moved on the days of eating mutton five years ago when they had boiled mutton and and gruel and that's part of the new york times's campaign to do down britain as you know it's very low okay he's off i really think we've got to stop at this point thanks so much for coming on. That was great. Thank you so much for having me. It's whetted my appetite. I might go and have, well, I don't know what I'm going to have. Go and eat your cockapoo or whatever it's called.
嗯，他们当时在发表一些荒谬的报道，不是吗？说英国烹饪已经超越了五年前吃羊肉的日子，当时他们吃的是水煮羊肉和稀粥，这是《纽约时报》贬低英国运动的一部分，你知道的，这真的很低级。好了，他不说了。我真的觉得我们必须在这个时候停下来。非常感谢你能来。这太棒了。非常感谢邀请我。这勾起了我的食欲。我可能会去吃点……嗯，我不知道我要吃什么。去吃你的“考克·阿·皮格”或者不管它叫什么吧。
Go and roast some mutton stuffed with oysters. And Penn's book, just to repeat, is Scoff, a history of food and class in Britain. It's brilliant. I swallowed it down in a couple of evenings. And the Sunday Times critic on the back says it's sharp, rich and super in Britain. It's brilliant. I swallowed it down in a couple of evenings. And the Sunday Times critic on the back says it's sharp, rich and superbly readable. Vogler reveals why we eat what we do today. And it is fascinating. And I think that Sunday Times critic was Dominic. So it must be true. Thanks ever so much. Bye bye. Thank you. Bye. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
去烤点填满生蚝的羊肉吧。彭的书，再重复一遍，是《大吃大喝：英国的食物与阶级历史》。它太棒了。我在几个晚上内就把它读完了。封底上的《星期日泰晤士报》书评说它尖锐、丰富且极其可读。福格勒揭示了为什么我们今天会吃我们所吃的食物。这太迷人了。而且我认为那位《星期日泰晤士报》的评论员就是多米尼克。所以这一定是真的。非常感谢。再见。谢谢。再见。再见。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来发表评论。